l'espace Albert Camus à Maurepas a
révélé sa saison culturelle pour l'année
2023 2024 et pour nous parler de la
programmation l'adjointe au maire à la
culture de la Ville Véronique rocher
alors pour cette nouvelle saison vous
avez mis l'accent sur la musique on va
avoir des concerts de rock de métal de
jazz et même du gospel exactement
des années 80 aussi éduc classique et du
classique en particulier avec Joaquim
Horse les qui est compositeur et
pianiste américain et qui revisite la
musique classique à la sauce caribéenne
en imaginant Beethoven Mozart Mandelson
ou même Chopin ayant vécu à Cuba
justement je vous propose d'écouter un
petit extrait en continu d'en parler
juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là on a entendu la musique qui l'a
rendu célèbre c'est Beethoven in Havana
c'est un pari ambitieux de vouloir
mélanger le classique comme ça avec de
la rumba cubaine oui effectivement après
je pense que c'est aussi ce qui va
attirer
la musique classique quelquefois
n'attire pas beaucoup la jeunesse c'est
même d'autres là je pense que c'est un
vrai défi quoi de faire découvrir
redécouvrir ces musiques
Gabriel parce que justement l'objectif
c'est de faire que la musique intéresse
tout le monde peu importe l'âge peu
importe le style qu'on a l'habitude
d'écouter exactement surtout que nous on
a un conservatoire qui est assez
important à Maurepas et donc on a déjà
un public important avec le
Conservatoire mais il faut l'élargir ce
public
et donc voilà c'est un moyen de faire
découvrir à tous ces jeunes qui jouent
des instruments que on peut imaginer et
travailler autrement en tout cas si
souhaitez assister à ce concert ce sera
le 1er mars 2024 un autre rendez-vous
important un espace Albert Camus
Véronique rocher c'est Marianne James
elle va faire un one woman show exact
sur la voie exactement Marianne Marianne
James en chef de cœur pour nous amourpa
humour et interaction avec le public
garanti cours de chant et conseils en
direct et donc c'est un spectacle aussi
interactif avec le public exactement
voilà c'est l'intérêt et l'enjeu de ce
one man show effectivement et donc
est-ce que vous savez comment est-ce
qu'elle va interagir avec le public
comment ça va se passer alors je ne sais
pas d'avance comment elle va se passer
si ce n'est ce que j'ai déjà vu de ce
qu'elle fait déjà donc elle peut donner
des conseils pour dégager sa voix se
mettre en route
voilà c'est des petites choses comme ça
et puis après elle fait faire découvrir
aussi les tonalités de sa voix enfin bon
voilà en tout cas c'est rires garanti
j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression
aussi garantie alors toujours dans le
thème de l'humour vous allez aussi
accueillir 3 4 d'improvisation théâtrale
c'est un peu un rendez-vous à Maurepas
oui depuis des années c'est un
rendez-vous ouais on a un public fidèle
qui vient chaque année une fois par
trimestre de découvrir ou redécouvrir ce
catch d'impro et alors c'est quoi ces
quatre d'improvisation théâtrale alors
c'est du théâtre mais pareil du théâtre
plutôt humoristique souvent et qui peut
être interactif aussi d'ailleurs
donc voilà des personnages très
différents sur scène il va y avoir aussi
des personnalités dans ces quatre
d'improvisation puisqu'il va y avoir un
autre sa mère
qui est un très grand humoriste et donc
vous faites aussi la part belle au
spectacle jeune public pour cette
nouvelle saison
travailler auprès du jeûne public auprès
scolaire pour leur faire découvrir la
culture notre patrimoine
[Musique]
je pense que dans l'éducation c'est
juste indispensable et donc
l'image allez-y non mais oui les petites
musiques de pluie ce sont les musiciens
de Chapi Chapo qui se donnent donc un
samedi après-midi c'est un concert de
jouets électro époque musique c'est un
concert des années 80 qui redonne vie
donc à cette à cette décennie très
joyeuse et très et très insouciante
voilà et on se retrouve au milieu d'une
chambre au milieu de jouer et on
découvre voilà toutes ces redécouvre
toute cette musique on va découvrir
ensemble je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait là encore
[Musique]
alors on l'a vu sur ces images il
compose leur musique à partir
d'instruments joués au final c'est leur
marque de fabrique exactement sont des
jouets des objets insolites des jouets
vintage qu'on trouve quasiment plus
qu'ils ont amplifié et
donc voilà des mini synthétiseurs voilà
et leur résulte ce qu'on a entendu une
petite partition multicolore et voilà et
alors pour les plus petits aussi il y
aura un spectacle de marionnettes ou
alors une comédie sur l'histoire de
France oui de spectacle pour les pour
les jeunes publics oui effectivement
alors l'histoire de alors c'est sur le
ton un ton assez humoristique aussi ce
sont des deux personnages le professeur
et les et les lèvres on va dire qui
qui se questionne voilà
plutôt sur un ton assez humoristique
effectivement et on découvre
un peu d'histoire un peu de date des
dates historiques et
en apprendre un peu plus sur l'histoire
de France de différemment pour attirer
là aussi les enfants merci beaucoup
Véronique rocher d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plein si vous êtes
intéressé par certains spectacles vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà réservé votre
place sur le site internet qui s'affiche
juste en dessous de votre écran